my food wine
boy
lady the high-level feed the papa
what then
well hey guys from become a welcome
video my pure friend tag should go
darling Dawa Alice because going to be
as a controversial and a lot of people
don't judge me for doing this video so
obviously because you're not in my shoes
and you don't we know up in screamish
easy for you to say what you want to say
but marriage is doing something really
hard for me I really wanted to get
married for a long time but it's not
easy but you know I mention we met
somebody which I'm kind of fee and yes
we are going up but me our intentions
are to get married
so please do hold adjustments to
yourself then I want to do this video my
girlfriend time to obviously talk a bit
about each other and I do videos about
you know her own volition stuff like
that and obviously we're not doing
anything around my belief so I just
wanted you guys to leave there meet her
and obviously I don't want to seem like
a hypocrite so forth you know it's all I
can do it just as your friend time so
yeah then I will introduce you guys to
her she's behind the camera she's being
with the buttons yeah get me tonight
yeah sorry woman when it comes to coming
in a really good yeah so she goes I'm
join you in a minute okay guys so I
don't want to keep it any longer I'm
going to call my other half here and
don't be shy and we're going to go
through some questions that you guys
asked us on Facebook and so yeah I'm
gonna be estranged to it okay first
question
you ready don't be afraid
what do you like the most about me I was
the most like it back about it and don't
make me show you I like the fact that
he's kind and loving okay I like the
fact that he does shower one downside is
that he never has time to me yeah but
Collins weekend I underneath but I'm
Sunday to in Hyde Park all the time but
I needed a high pass
so you know how cool enough okay next
question that what things I know you
about each other me is when you eat you
just that's done just annoys we're not
eating foods I'm out here that is
amazing
but what annoys you about me let's start
what they annoy me about you but don't
be sad just to see what it is
it's annoying where you don't listen to
me oh and your moustache annoys me
Wow got positive numbers - and see that
I'm just going to ignore that and move
on to the next question
okay how did we meet you'll answer that
why should I answer that what Holly
noses and we met in the Hyde Park few
weeks ago why you is giving dower
yeah remain high coughs don't it'll what
did he do okay okay so the next question
how long have you been together three
weeks around three weeks yes rockin
around that time yeah follows me but not
three weeks yeah
okay next question okay guys so I'm
gonna go through a couple other
questions
this one's a little bit judgmental and
people just asking silly stuff I don't
really care cause I don't need to prove
myself to anyone you know Allah knows my
heart so yeah one of the questions is
don't you feel Allah to be honest I
don't know what what's that got to do
anything you know I don't but just cuz I
have a girlfriend does it mean I don't
feel a lot so I think it's a ridiculous
question to be honest
next question are you misleading people
these people's choice you know if they
if they want to see this and do it I
don't care you know cuz you know I
thought I've got my girlfriend though
you know you know I don't need to care
what people think about me are you
sitting publicly is the narration that
says the ones that send publicly don't
peek also the only people that will not
be forgiven other ones that sin publicly
Turner's are we care as you know as long
as I've got my girlfriend you know I
don't
you know next question why aren't you
married
why don't need to get married when have
a girlfriend come on guys use your logic
sense you know okay last question what
if she was your sister but she ain't my
sister though she she she's my
girlfriend
you know the difference this time your
friend you might be open you're early
yes what video was doing my girlfriend
tag Ruby laughs oh come on what this
friend tag yeah well these questions are
boo yeah I'll do a best friend tennis
look no no no okay guys
since the entertainments over I think
it's time that we get a little bit
serious now that we've had a little bit
of jockey tag and you guys before I
really have a girlfriend you need to
watch my videos once again now why did I
do this video brothers and sisters what
you need to understand is that one thing
that really really hits my heart and
really bores my brain sometimes is the
fact of certain men hypocrite men out
there who do certain acts normally that
I'm talking about both Muslim youtubers
and both Muslim individuals in general
this is not just targeted at one
specific individual no this is targeted
as a whole and I want to reiterate this
once again is that we have individuals
out there and on a platform and they're
on a social platform and they do
girlfriend tags or for example they're
out there and they have a girlfriend and
they walk around or pride and the
individuals on a public platform really
hurt me more why because at least an
individual who has a girlfriend is wrong
but he doesn't have that mass influence
on a vast amount of people to make it
seem like it's okay when it's not what
really hurts me is and it's a big type
of hypocrisy that you go out there and
make a video whatever it may be and be
like my girlfriend tag I challenge
anyone look I will put my life down you
know I would if bitten was halal I will
put 10,000 pounds down if that was your
sister would you allow your sister to do
a video with her boyfriend seeing my
boyfriend tag I challenge any man both
in the public plat
form and you brothers that are watching
it watching this video for yourself
while lying by Allah you guys know never
in a million years if anyone utter your
sister's name you will go crazy you were
going a mad one you know this then my
brother my dear brother why is it that
you go out and I'm talking to
individuals Muslim youtubers whoever it
may be me whoever it is my brother why
do you go out there and do a video
saying my girlfriend tag you have a
following but what are you trying to
promote what like what are you exactly
trying to do you're seeing okay look
don't judge me but you need to
understand we're human we're not robot
how can you say okay don't judge me I'm
not perfect etc by the way guys watch my
girlfriend tag how does that both work
how do you expect an individual to say
you know what let me go do commit zina
show you my girlfriend pictures do a
girlfriend tag we're on holiday but guys
don't judge me now you need to
understand that there must be something
going on in your brain that's not making
you understand and I don't mean this in
a disrespectful way you are sincere
maybe I can say you know what I assume
the best in my brother and say you are
sincere whoever you are you are sincere
but the actions that you're doing does
it follow the sincerity that you have in
your heart because you need to
understand two things you might be
sincere but are you following the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him with
your actions is good for me to go and
say you know what fudge it is to rock
are a few extra sincere today I'm going
to pray five you know cause a few
sincere you know I want to give that
extra to Allah I'm gonna go pray five
raka would not be accepted of me did the
Prophet peace be upon him do that no he
didn't so you need to understand you
being sincere doesn't mean anything now
brothers and sisters we as individual
sin I'm not an angel I seen myself but
we are trying our best to avoid sins
doing since a private alone is bad
anyways you know because you are making
the one who created you witnessed that
but now what you're doing is you are
publicizing it forget publicize it now
you're glorifying it so there's
individuals Muslims that may not know
right from wrong they're gonna watch you
and look up to you and be like yeah
girlfriend tag so
I can have a girlfriend too because it
doesn't matter cause I'm sincere my
heart is clean if your heart is so clean
it should reflect upon your actions it's
not my heart is clean if your heart is
clean it should reflect upon your
actions your behavior if it's not then
you need to question yourself are you
doing this for a lot for the people you
are you trying to please if it's the
people you're gonna try your best to
make them happy all your life and you
know what they're never going to be
happy you are never going to be happy
doing it for the sake of Allah is what
matters and brother I really want to
reiterate this please understand where
I'm coming from imagine once again your
sister doing a boyfriend tag your sister
saying hey I met my boyfriend in the
park know me my boyfriend you know what
I like I like I like his shoulders all
my boyfriend you know what we had our
first kiss there and then how would you
feel please for the sake of argument you
are a man I'm a man we know how we would
feel then why promote this hypocrisy why
promote it in a way where is is it's
like a something so glorifying and then
turn to people and say don't judge me we
would judge from what's apparent so guys
I just want to say to the brothers fear
loss wonho Tyler when it comes to these
matters you wouldn't want that for your
sister don't go out and do this to other
people's sisters and sisters well I just
want to reiterate something know your
value these videos ignore them
what like you are worth more than being
a girlfriend if you are good enough to
be a girl from but not good enough to be
a wife then the individual that you're
with is clearly using you and know that
if a man is making you his girlfriend
not his wife he is not a man at all I
don't call such individuals men they're
not men if it's if it's a true man he
will come
so if he's a true man a true man will
come and ask for your hand like a man
not be like a little boy and say you're
my girlfriend and down the line get
bored and say you know what I'm gonna
move on to somebody else and Brahman
says I want to leave you guys with two
things number one you have good
intentions you are sincere mashallah
that's good but if you actually don't
follow the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah
will sell them then know that it's not
going to be accepted if you want your
worship to be accepted be sincere have
the correct intentions and follow what
the Prophet did and try your best not to
fit into society one lie he be like we
love
Islam we are proud to be Muslims may
Allah keep us on throttle mustaqim may
Allah protect us from ever you know
doing girlfriend tags or whatever it may
be or having your friends in without
people not even seeing may Allah protect
us from that and wallah I will say once
again we are proud to be a Muslim we
don't need to show the core our religion
to anybody or to fit into society
my sisters know your value my brothers
fear Allah may Allah o Allah grant every
single one of you guys Jannah share this
video
assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh